know south dakota is among the states
where abortion services would
immediately become illegal if roe is
overturned janet shamley visited a
clinic inside falls where providers are
taking extraordinary measures to ensure
women do have access for now
dr sarah traxler has full days at the
planned parenthood clinic in sioux falls
but her day started hours before she
even walked in the door what's your
round trip commute in miles
oh i don't know
hundreds yes
[Laughter]
even though traxler is the chief medical
officer of the clinic the only abortion
provider in south dakota she lives in
minnesota
her trip to work involves going to the
minneapolis airport taking the flight
being met by a security officer in sioux
falls for her safety
then a drive to the clinic i was afraid
i wasn't actually going to be able to
make it
a commute the mom of two has taken
monthly for the last seven years i sort
of feel at some level if i don't do it
and the other three physicians who do it
with me who else is going to do it there
wouldn't be
anything for these patients the clinic
says it hasn't been able to get in-state
doctors who fear harassment this nurse
is the health clinic manager why aren't
there more clinics in this state it's
because of the atmosphere in the state
and how unfriendly it is and how unsafe
it makes people feel to work here also
to seek the care that they
are allowed to seek south dakota is one
of six states with just one abortion
provider and it has some of the nation's
strictest abortion laws
including a 72-hour waiting period
between consultation and procedure
regardless of whether it's a surgical or
medication abortion i've noticed on
their charts dr traxler has to make two
trips a week because the same doctor is
required for both appointments you're
making a big sacrifice but what are the
patients telling you about their
journeys
i mean i think that their sacrifice is
more than mine they are leaving their
children they are leaving their jobs
they are losing wages they are having to
find travel money republican governor
christie nome is pushing legislation
that would require three trips for a
medication abortion the consultation and
one for each dose of the abortion pill
she argues it's out of concern for
women's safety
if it passes the clinic says logistics
would make it almost impossible to
continue offering medication abortions
these restrictions are going to
disproportionately impact already
marginalized communities that already
have a difficult time accessing you know
health care in general but abortion care
specifically on this day dr traxler saw
10 patients
everything went to plan until her return
flight the only fight home canceled due
to weather in a state where nothing
about abortion is easy
for cbs mornings i'm janet chameleon